der film camino oder your name gestern
heute und für immer wieder in der
deutschen fassung heißt ist ein
absolutes kronjuwel des neueren anime
also wenn man anime filme kennt denkt
man vielleicht dann ja sagte yalcins
reise ins wunderland fliegen schlösser
und so das ist dann mehr so fantasy haft
dieses ist naja magischer realismus wenn
man es so nennen will also das heißt es
hat sehr viel mehr mit erfahrungswelten
zu tun die uns so umgeben
es ist aber trotzdem eine fantastische
geschichte es ist nämlich ein
körpertausch oder wenn man es umgekehrt
sehen will den serien tausch zwischen
einem provinz mädchen namens mit 2 und
einem tokioter jungennamen stucky sie
wohnt im hintersten dorf und heißt mit
zwei bis dreimal die woche stecken wir
auf einmal im körper das andere auslöser
schlaf ursache unbekannt
und man denkt bei sowas natürlich an
filme wie ich weiß nicht wie ich mit
ellen barkin mann/frau tauschen die
körper oder big mit tom hanks älterer
junge wird jüngerer junge und umgekehrt
das sind mehr oder weniger komödie in
dieser film fängt 20 minuten lang als
eine art komödie an wir müssen
herausfinden dass sie da die körper und
die seele getauscht haben
dann probieren sich 20 minuten lang aus
und dann passiert eine katastrophe bz
was enthüllt sich eine katastrophe und
dann hat der film relativ viel zu tun
mit filmen wie melancholia oder mit dem
bergman film obwohl er trotzdem nicht
schwerblütig wird so dass man es nicht
ertragen kann
aber in der tat enthält viele
temperaturen die man so von gefühlen und
gedanken kennt die ein bisschen mehr
dimensionen haben als nur es ist zum
lachen oder es ist irgendwie gar show
fantastico oder so es ist ein wahnsinnig
reicher film
die sonne scheint hier auch nicht lange
wo man ihn also die tatsache wieder
alltagsdinge wie ein handy display oder
so eingebettet werden in diese
wasserfahrt geschichte mit den
hintergründen und so macht sich einfach
gedanken über sozusagen ebenen von
kommunikation und ebenen von erfahrungen
die wir alle kennen für die es aber
eigentlich auf der ebene des
fotografierens dieser realität sozusagen
keine sprachen gibt es erfindet eine
sprache für sowas und in allen filmen
von makoto shinkai geht es genau um das
und diese ganzen geschichten sozusagen
macht der makoto shinkai voraussetzungen
für bilder aber auch für musik für
geräusche für für alles das womit man
ihm spielen kann wenn man filme drehen
und ich würde sagen wer kino überhaupt
liebt über den moment hinaus dass man
beeindruckt ist und weinen muss oder so
sondern wo man sagt dass eine erfahrung
die ich außerhalb von kino auch bei
anderer kunst nicht machen kann muss in
diesem film gehen
also man sollte ihn nicht sehen obwohl
es im zeichentrickfilm ist sondern weit
im zeichen der film ist bei ja das kino
als trickfilm auch angefangen hat also
die ersten kinofilme die ersten jahr als
belustigung mit diesem medium hatten ja
viel damit zu tun dass man da sachen
machen kann die man zum beispiel theater
nicht machen kann
mit schnitt mit raum mit allen möglichen
manipulationen und die sind hier in
einer solchen tiefe eingesetzt dass man
sozusagen bei einem film der einfach nur
schauspieler hätte die abfotografiert
werden gar nicht machen könnte weil
beispielsweise die frage wie man die
person ist die man ist wie die zu tun
hat mit dem raum in dem man sich aufhält
hier natürlich gesteuert wird darüber
dass jedes detail dieser räume
kontrolliert ist jedes verdammte
reiskorn jeder lichtreflex alles ist
geschrieben alles ist komponiert alles
ist sozusagen von der subjektivität des
großartigen regisseurs makoto shinkai
der das gemacht hat eingesetzt um dieses
bild gedicht sozusagen herzustellen und
das heißt du hast eine klaviatur von
gefühlen und von gedanken auf denen da
gespielt wird wo man tatsächlich sich
sozusagen in die hände eines
erstklassigen wahnsinnigen begeben kann
ich bin ja ich habe keine ahnung wie man
sie spät nach deutschland kommt ich habe
auch keine ahnung warum sie ihn erstmal
nur an zwei tagen in kinos zeigen
nämlich am donnerstag dem 11 januar und
am sonntag dem 14 januar mit knapp 130
kinos bundesweit das ist eine ziemliche
vorsicht wenn man bedenkt dass das einer
der erfolgreichsten filme die in japan
gemacht wurden er wahr ist dass er zum
beispiel auch in china die dämme
gebrochen hat china ist traditionellen
land das keineswegs mit offenen armen
alles aufnimmt was aus dem land kommt
das ja immerhin nach china besetzt hat
und ziemlich problematisch dort
gewirtschaftet hat es wird wenn ich es
richtig sehe im mai eine dvd geben für
das deutsche publikum aber als jemand
der vor zwei jahren als es dem film
schon gab ihnen auch mal im kino sehen
durfte kann ich nur sagen wenn ihr das
irgendwie schafft ins kino zu gehen
an diesen zwei tagen tut es weil dafür
solche filme ist das kino erfunden
wurden einst wollte ich dir noch sagen
egal wo du bist auf der welt ich werde
dich finden
bist du
wie ist sein name